welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's webinar analysis of
cannabis for pesticides and mycotoxins
using u P LC ms/ms
and gc/ms ms it is presented by marian
Twohig ph.d principal scientist for
scientific operation about waters
corporation my name is Judy O'Rourke and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before begin I would like
to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits now about further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Twohig I will
now turn the presentation over to her
thank you so much Judy and hello
everybody so today we're going to talk a
little bit about the analysis of
cannabis for pesticides and mycotoxins
using a combination of both you P LC
ms/ms and also GCM SNS so just to give a
brief overview or what we're going to
talk about we'll mention some of the
challenges in pesticide testing both
those associated with the variation in
the regulatory requirements and the
variation in the number of compounds and
the types of compounds and also the
action limits that are being tested for
in each u.s. state and also in Canada
and then there is the functional
difficulty of trying to measure a wide
variety of pesticides at trace
in the in the presence of endogenous
materials in the cannabis plant that are
present at much higher concentrations
and sometimes the physical and chemical
properties of the pesticides under test
and the endogenous chemicals within the
plant overlap and so they are extracted
out together and this can lead to
inaccuracies in the measurement but
there are some sample preparation and
cleanup options that can be helpful and
we'll talk about some of those and then
we'll run through an analytical workflow
and show some applications data and then
very briefly we will summarize so at the
beginning of this study we we had to
decide which direction to go in so in
essence we had to take an analytical
journey and this was a journey in
experimentation and I'd like to go
through some of this journey with you
and just like any time when we embark
upon any method development exercise we
we do so to try to find the correct
analytical path and a good way to
describe this is a quote from the port
and printmaker William Blake when he
said the true method of knowledge is
through experimentation so our journey
began with the Oregon list of pesticides
which is a list of pesticides that has
been established as achievable using a
single LC ms/ms platform only and we
were able to achieve the action levels
and satisfy the regulatory requirements
for the analysis of Oregon pesticides
using the combination of instruments and
column that you see on this slide an
acuity H class and a tangent quadrupole
there were some challenging compounds to
deal with but we were able to overcome
those challenges and able to see them at
the required levels and so more
information about this study is
available on the waters website using
the application code shown in the corner
of the slide
it was when we try to analyze more
extensive lists such as the California
pesticide residue lists that we began to
encounter problems and some of those
problems stemmed really from some of the
pesticides that are on that list and
also the action levels that are required
some of the pesticides aren't on the
California list have not been
traditionally analyzed using traditional
LC ms/ms sources such as electro spray
ionization or atmospheric pressure
chemical ionization or APC I and while
we were thinking about the the study we
were also keeping an eye on the Canadian
list which also had some pesticides on
that list that job had been
traditionally analyzed by GCM SMS and
what is the goal of any analysis what
should we strive for well we want to
have a set of tools that can enable us
to provide accurate and reproducible
quantitation even in the presence of the
natural variability that we as
analytical chemists experience on on a
daily basis and because we really can't
control what samples are going to be
analyzed or the variation and hiren
twith in those samples the best way we
thought to approach this problem was to
try and plan first
try to cover every eventuality and this
really has been or the way we've
approached the problem of analyzing a
large number of structurally diverse
pesticides in the presence of this very
complex matrix a long way we encountered
some challenges and in my experience
it's rare not to encounter challenges
but the challenges can be useful because
ultimately we learn from them and they
shape the pathway to the final method so
of course one of the challenges that we
faced was matrix suppression due to the
complexity of the matrix itself and so
what we're looking at on this slide is
we're looking at two full scan ms
chromatograms on the top we have the
electrospray negative ion
from a diagram and on the bottom we have
electrospray positive ion chromatograph
and we've extracted out the isobaric
mass-to-charge ratio of 357 for the
acidic compounds th CA and CB da from
the top trace the negative ion trace and
then from the lower chromatogram we've
extracted out the master charge ratio of
315 from the THC and sorry 315 which is
THC and CBD from the positive ion
chromatograph and this is anesthesia
nitrile extraction of a cannabis flower
extract and you can see in the shaded
rectangle which is at the the back end
of the Kamata gram from 10 to 13 minutes
we've extracted out some very high
intensity master charge ratios and this
is really the typical area of the
chromatogram where the cannabinoids are
loose and if you have trace level
components closely eluting or Co losing
adjacent to these Peaks then it's going
to lead to inaccuracies in in the
measurement charge competition on this
slide we're looking at radar
chromatograms and radar describes a mode
of analysis where we can simultaneously
analyze both ms full scan data with your
targeted mrm data and radar it can be
very useful because it reveals that
which is unseen in a static experiment
like an M R M where the Quadra poles are
fixed on a particular precursor mass and
a product mass so you can see the
background because if you don't go
looking for it you will never see it in
an MRI M a question and on the top we
can see the red trace which is the
electrospray positive ion trace is very
in it's very intense it's been
superimposed on top of the negative ion
full scan trace which is in green and
once again this has been highlighted by
the shaded rectangle to show the region
of the chromatogram where the
cannabinoids
elute and where a lot of the pesticides
aleut as well so this is undoubtedly
going to lead to some sort of charge
competition remembering again that the
the pesticide
our present at ppb levels very low
levels and the cannabinoids and other
components are present at orders of
magnitude higher and we did see some
clear evidence of matrix suppression so
as an example of this we're showing a
cannabis flower that has been extracted
with a sieve nitrile and when we spiked
this into a standard for the compound
Spiro Meza Fang which was analyzed by
electrospray positive we spiked it at a
hundred ppb
we could see a good signal for the
primary iron and the secondary iron
however when we pre spiked this same
level into the cannabis flower and then
subsequently extracted it with the c2
nitrile we got no signal so we were
experiencing charge competition here now
this situation can be alleviated by
doing further matrix dilution or doing
some sort of cleanup of that acid
nitrile extraction and this could also
be misconstrued as some sort of a
recovery issue but this was really a
suppression issue matrix suppression
issue so we then decided to look at an
AP CI experiment and using the same
samples we spiked we analyzed the 100
ppb standard and once again we had a
very good signal for about the primary
iron and the secondary iron and when we
analyze the pre spike this time we had a
good signal for for both the primary and
the secondary line in that extracted
cannabis matrix when we calculated the
matrix suppression using a PCI it was
about 27% now we tried to analyze more
of the compounds with a PCI but we
didn't have the same coverage for all of
the compounds at the action levels that
were necessary in the in the matrix now
higher sensitivity mass spectrometers
are available and we intend to do some
further study to see what the data
quality looks like on these systems in a
PCI
when we moved from the Oregon list of
compounds to the California list of
compounds we gained a new pesticide and
that pesticide is a spinach horan and
naturally when we were trying to develop
method for the California list of
compounds we use the same gradient that
we had for California and you can see in
the first chromatogram that the
pesticides spin of Santa T is completely
coaling with spinach hora and these
compounds are structurally very similar
and when they undergo collision induced
dissociation they fragment identically
in the collision cell and the difference
in the structure between those two
spinosad E and spinet Oram is only two
hydrogen's so there is a form of
spinosad e that has two carbon 13 atoms
in its structure and it will give rise
to a signal in the same channel as span
bennett orem because of the proximity of
their precursor masses and there they're
saying product ions so it's better if
you chromatographic ly resolve those
which we have done in the second
chromatogram you can see a small signal
at nine point seven minutes and that's
the contribution from that that form of
spinosad e that has two carbon 13 atoms
in its structure and when you have a
multi residue analyte detection like
this and with the sometimes their co
Aleutians it's worth looking to see if
there are any structural similarities
that might give rise to a signal from
one mrm channel of one pesticide into
another and we did evaluate some sample
extraction and cleanup options that are
applicable to multi residue and light
detection so we mentioned some of some
of the interferences in a previous slide
the the cannabinoids can be potential
interferences but also the the terpenes
that can also interfere in these
illusion
an earlier retention time but there are
some other components that are common to
most plans that can also cause problems
such as phospholipids which can build
you up on the injector or the column
there are facts which can precipitate
when the sample is diluted for liquid
chromatography and there's also
chlorophyll which can contaminate GC
injectors so what can we do can we get
rid of the matrix this is slider
showings comparison of the physical
chemical properties between pyrethrin 1
and THC their molecular weights are
quite similar and their log P or log ko
W the partition coefficients is also
quite similar and what this means is
that in reverse phase chromatography
situations those two will elude quite
close together and when we're talking
about sample preparation options it'll
be difficult to separate one without
impacting the other one most pesticides
are neutral or they're very weakly
acidic aflatoxins are neutral but okra
toxin a is acidic so clean up with a PS
a solvent will retain all four toxin and
result in reduced recovery for this
compound this is also true of the acidic
growth regulator to mini-site but we did
see some benefits of using PSA as a
solvent for our cleanup technique that
we employed for the study and so what
does what does um we use dispersive SP
and what what benefits does dispersive
SPE offer to us it can clean up facts
phospholipids and chlorophyll it was
performed following the initial seizure
nitrile extraction and it was a very
simple way of performing the cleanup for
all of these analytes because the tube
that it was used to perform the cleanup
is pre packed with the contents that you
see at the lower half of the slide and
when we compared some other sample
preparation techniques that are
applicable for multi residue analysis
this dispersive SPE cleanup had them
benefits for the majority of compounds
in terms of the visual evidence that the
dispersive SPE is our benefit you can
see a comparison here are the anesthesia
nitrile extraction only where there's no
dispersive SPE versus one where
dispersive SPE has been performed
following that initially seizure nitrile
extraction and you can see the
difference in color on this this
photograph and we performed a matrix
depression study using the Oregon list
of compounds and this compared
anesthesia nitrile extraction only
versus one where dispersive SPE was
performed following that initialization
hydraulic structure all of the
pesticides which in this this bar chart
are arranged in order of retention time
were spiked at 0.2 microgram per gram
and for replicates of each were
evaluated for the study and we can see
here that the red bars indicate where
there was no dispersive SPE performed so
just in a sequin I trial extraction and
the blue bars indicate where we perform
dispersive SPE though in this case the
percentage depression is shown on the
vertical axis and a lower bar is better
the shaded area indicates compounds that
collude with the cannabinoids and so
what we found for this study was that
the the youths artists parts of SPE
almost always resulted in a decrease in
the matrix effects and this means that
you're not what you're doing when you
perform dispersive SPE is you are
reducing the amount of interfering
compounds that you're injecting onto
your system that can lead to problems
later on with robustness of the method
we performed a total method recovery
study where we studied two concentration
levels point 1 microgram per gram and
0.5 micro grant program and 6 replicates
of each of these and we compared the
response to the pre spiked samples for
each of these levels to the matrix
matched
of the same concentration and what we
found was that the recovery for most of
the pesticides were in the range of 80
to 120 percent so you can see from this
graph that it's very easy to tell where
the recovery is low and we mentioned we
mentioned the two compounds that were
causing problems with recovery and that
they were diminish I and also okra toxin
a and we are working on novel ways of
trying to improve the recovery for both
of those compounds and so can we do this
reproducibly can we do this extraction
reproducibly the standard deviation were
shown above the the bars on the previous
graph but just for clarity just to pull
out the information and show a little
bit more more clearly on this side we
selected a number of pesticides on that
I know as well by electrospray some that
don't ionize well by electro spray and a
negative iron compound and we performed
a study where we looked at the response
from five pre spiked levels which were
spiked at a level of point one microgram
per gram and we can see that the
percentage RS DS for those five spike
levels for all of the pesticides were
less than 10 percent while we're talking
about matrix suppression and complexity
I would just like to mention very
quickly the the benefits of using agar
column column protection it's a very
cost efficient way of protecting the the
lifetime of your column and it does not
have any negative impacts on the
separation efficiency and it's very
useful in situations where you are not
performing any sort of cleanup in
situations where we cannot confidently
and reproducibly reach the action levels
of any particular state using an LC
ms/ms platform only we propose the use
of both an LC ms/ms platform and also a
GCM SMS platform and this allows us to
fully cover the entire list of
pesticides the LC amenable pesticides
and also the GC amino pesticides
using the single dispersive SPE extract
we can analyze that same extract on
either system and it also adds a layer
of flexibility in the event that there
are matrix difficulties for any
particular technique because they're the
complementary information on both
platforms in addition to that it allows
an extra layer of flexibility because if
the regulations were to change and
pesticides were added to a nice tag list
that would require analysis by GCM SMS
you would have all of the tools in your
analytical artillery to attack any of
those problems so there will be some
pesticides that you can analyze by LC
and they will go better on the LC
platform some will do better on the GC
platform but you will have some overlap
between both platforms that can be
analyzed on both chlordane isomers the
citizen trans thoradine isomers for
example they resolve better on the GC
column this is also true for the Spirax
amine isomers and really the decision to
use both an LC ms/ms platform and a GCM
SMS platform originated when we we tried
to analyze some of the GC amino
pesticides by either electrospray or APC
ion the LC platform we did a data
quality assessment in comparison and the
the data quality was better on the GC so
that is where the the decision came from
so now we're going to take a look at
some applications data and this this
stage was really aimed at trying to meet
the california mycotoxin pesticide at
micro toxin and pesticide residue
regulatory requirements and more
information about the study is on our
website using the application code
listed below
this shows the slide shows a snapshot of
the the inlet methods for the the you
PLC method and the the GC method in this
case we use a 0t q GC i won't go too
much detail into the experimental
methods but know
that if you have any questions about any
of the details that you see on the
slides you can reach out and contact us
before you can collect any analytical
data you're going to have to have your
suite of mrm transitions to collect 8:00
on the pesticides or the micro toxins
and it could be challenging to organize
all of that information because you have
in the case of California have 66
pesticides and they will have
confirmatory transitions as well so
having software that can streamline that
process and that can help you to develop
the methods based on existing databases
can be very beneficial to the efficiency
of getting started in the laboratory so
one such example is Kwan pedia which is
an essentially it's an encyclopedia of
mrm transitions and analytical
information that can help you get
started quickly and you can start from a
blank slate and using a number of
questions and a decision tree you can
end up with an MS acquisition method and
an MS processing method with associated
LC methods based on databases for either
the LC ms/ms platform or the GCMs MS
platform and it really increases the
efficiency of Method generation and also
it reduces the the transcription errors
but if there are pesticides that you
need to analyze that are not in the
database we can add those very easily
using some of the auto tune features so
intelli starch can be used for the
optimization of a small number of
analytes and quan optimize it can be
used when you have to optimize a larger
number so batch batch optimization of
compounds so what we're looking at now
is we're looking at the LC ms/ms
analysis of some pesticides that were
only are the california list but not on
the oregon list so Mebane fast
fenhexamid spinner tourim dimethyl
Markkula fast and for pyro fast
they were all
pree spiked at a level of point one
microgram program in canvas flower and
then subsequently extracted using the
extraction protocol that was just
detailed in the presentation and so you
can see we have a good signal for all of
those at the action level required for
the state of California we analyze the
mycotoxins as a subset of the pesticides
and here you're looking at aflatoxin G 2
G 1 B 2 and B 1 and okra toxin a which
as we mentioned where we're working on
trying to approve their recovery for
this one but at the action level for the
micro toxins we we could see those at
that action level and now we're looking
at some of the calibration data so we're
looking at the quantitation of
fenhexamid the residuals across the
calibration curve which that was tested
on the day which ranged from 25 to 500
ppb which is the in-sample concentration
or 2.5 to 50 ppb in vial they were less
than the residuals were less than 2% and
we're looking at the primary and
secondary ion for fenhexamid at the
lowest level which was a factor of 4
less than the action level required by
the state of California 25 ppb in sample
or 2.5 ppb in the vial and confidence in
your data is also very important so when
we were evaluating the data quality when
we also took into account the the
comparison of the primary to secondary
ion ratios or the quantitation to
qualification ion ratios between the
standards and that which was observed in
a matrix so in this experiment we're
looking at four standards which were
prepared separately and we have six
pre-strike samples that were prepared
separately and we compared the predicted
ratios from the primary to secondary ion
versus the actual and you can see that
using a the guide of the it being with
within 30 percent we were hoping to have
30 percent of that value between the
predicted and the actual being 30
percent of
standards that were analyzed in the same
batch and so we satisfied this criteria
with with the first experiment where we
compared the standards to the pre spikes
and this was also satisfied across our
matrix matched her okay so what about
precision and accuracy in this
experiment we're looking at ten QC
samples that were quantified against the
matrix match curve they were spiked at a
level of point one microgram program and
we assessed the standard deviation the
percentage rst and the bias we can see
that the standard deviation and the
percentage rst are less than 10% and the
bias for this experiment for this subset
of compounds that's displayed here was
less than 2.5% so for the GCMs ms site
this slide shows an expanded view of
some of the parameters for the z-bo qgc
that was used for this study and all of
these parameters were either default
settings or settings that were
recommended by the user manual or auto
tune settings and we did have a larger
subset of compounds that were that was
analyzed on the GC I think we had about
54 compounds on the GC panel so for an
example of this data a methyl parathion
is shown on this slide and once again we
can see the residuals were 4% across the
curve that was analyzed on that day the
calibration curve which ranged from 25
to a thousand ppb in sample
concentration or 2.5 to 100 ppb in vial
and once again we're showing the lowest
level of the curve that was analyzed on
that particular in this particular
experiment which was 25 PPP and that's a
factor of 4 or less than the action
level for the state of California we're
also looking here at the predicted
versus the actual primary to secondary
line ratios across the curve for methyl
parathion but methyl parathion is a
compound that could be analyzed on
either platform so here we're looking at
the comparison of the lc-ms
data versus the GCMs most Asia for
methyl parathion in in cannabis matrix
and on the LC ms/ms died it was spiked
2.1 microgram per gram and this this
experiment required a 5 micro liter
injection versus the GCMs ms where we
only had a 1 microliter injection and if
we look at the signal-to-noise it's it's
quite similar at at this level but we're
because we have a factor of 5 less on
column load for the GCMs ms i think
we're doing a little bit better
using the GCMs ms experiment for this
compound and differences like this can
also be due to how the matrix ionizes in
i'm in different ionization modes such
as electrospray and in this case ii i
what could be an interference in one
ayah zation mode may not necessarily
interfere in the other ionization so
what we're looking at here is we're
looking at the compounds for which the
GCMs ms data the quality of that data
it was superior when we we did a quality
assessment and comparison the quality of
the data was higher on the GCMs meds so
we made the decision to analyze these
compounds on the GCMs NS platform so
we're looking at captain at its action
level for the state of california point
seven microgram program and it was
analyzed as its teen HP i decadent
bifenthrin actually we've analyzed on LC
ms/ms and gc/ms ms but in this
particular strain there was an
interference in the LC ms/ms data which
prevented us from accurately quantifying
the compound at levels below 0.1
microgram per gram so we analyzed it on
the GCMs of s we had it on on that panel
as well and we were able to generate a
curve that had the same residuals and
dynamic range as the other pesticides
that we analyzed on platform and we
think there was an interference on the
GCMs ms platform as well we think it
might have been THC and it did cause
some some
Peak Distortion but it didn't prevent us
from quantifying the compound on that
platform system trans chlordane resolved
much better on the GC column when we
tried to analyze chlordane via a PCI on
the LC ms/ms platform we didn't really
see the same resolution between the the
system and trans loading and again the
data quality was better on the GCM SMS
platform it was an interesting compound
it did give rise to an atypical ion in
in the a PCI analysis on the L CMS
platform and pendrick's electro benzene
are our Quinta zine as it's also known
again the data quality was higher on the
GCM SNS so we aren't we analyzed it
there on that platform and this is the
type of matrix that could quickly result
in a loss of response from the inlet
liner or from the source components
becoming dirty and so it's important to
have a system that can withstand that
sort of that sort of matrix and so we're
looking at reproducibility study for the
GCM SMS platform using pentachloride row
benzene and bifenthrin across 50
injections and the the percentage or STS
for the response across those 50
injections was less than 12% for
pentatonix benzene and 6% for bifenthrin
so to summarize we have presented
quantitative and confirmatory pesticide
and mycotoxins and method for detection
of them in cannabis we have a broader
analyte coverage using both the LC and
the GC platform for the pesticides and
we have a simple engineer example
extraction which is you know it
increased ease leads to increased ease
decreased training needs and the reduced
matrix suppression possible using
dispersive SPE can lead to improved
robustness higher up time longer column
lifetime and less frequent source
paintings and
have the ability to implement these
methods quickly using existing databases
and software tools that can streamline
the implementation so where where have
we arrived on on our analytical journey
the truth is were still on the journey
we have a methods that can produce good
data and we will continue to adapt and
to change our methods as the regulations
change and as we learn more about how to
handle the cannabis matrix so I'd like
to conclude with a quote from a favorite
poet of mine and that's Alfred Lord
Tennyson who in 1833 when he wrote the
poem Ulysses was definitely not thinking
about cannabis analysis and Ulysses is a
poem about travel and following
knowledge and using travel to broaden
our experience and to forever grow in
wisdom and in learning with the final
line of that poem being to strive to
seek to find and not yield and so as we
continue on our own scientific voyage we
will continue to broaden our experience
and not yield even in the face of of
matrix difficulties so I would like to
acknowledge several people on this slide
this is my shortest side but it is
really the most important site because
it contains all of the names of the
people who contributed to the work and
made it what it what it is the
invaluable help of the scientists at
Provari laboratories Chris sutala
Rebecca Stevens and James Roush and my
colleagues at waters corporation in
particular kim tran and kerry organ
teeny who did most of this work gordon
Fujimoto Michael Young Doug Stevens and
Narendra Muruga and Andy Urban and I
would like to very much thank you for
your valuable time and for your
attention thank you thank you dr. to hit
for that informative presentation I
would also like to thank lab roots for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that this webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
2:00
twenty eight twenty nineteen and as a
final reminder our speaker will follow
up with your any questions you've
submitted via email that's all for now
thanks for joining us and we'll see you
next time goodbye